-President Biden used
his first
State of the Union address to
condemn Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine
and warned Putin
that he has no idea
what the U.S.
and its allies will do next.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
I have to say it just seems
exhausting
to be a Republican
politician these days.
Every minor inconvenience
is somehow a secret plot
to cancel you or indoctrinate
you into becoming
an Antifa Marxist woken-ista,
and I don't know what that is,
but I think it's bad.
Everything is a perceived slight
and you have to be constantly
outraged all the time.
Like yesterday, for example,
Senator Marco Rubio skipped
President Biden's first
State of the Union address,
where the President laid
out his plans for,
among other things,
deterring a brutal dictator,
who's invading
a sovereign country
and dealing
with a global pandemic.
And Rubio said it was
because he didn't want to
get tested for COVID.
-Not every Republican is here.
Marco Rubio, the Republican
senator from Florida,
said he wouldn't be attending
because he didn't have time
to get tested.
-Senator Rubio told
another media outlet
he wasn't taking
a COVID 19 test
because he didn't
have time for it.
-I'm sorry what?
You don't have time
to get your nose swabbed
for 10 seconds,
but there's two
possibilities here.
One, Marco Rubio is a bozo
pandering to a base
that somehow thinks
a 10-second nose swab
is an act of tyranny.
Or two,
he's been taking the wrong test.
[ Laughter ]
In which case I empathize
with this poor man.
I don't have time to go inside
that big metal tube
and get spooked by
all the banging.
Oh Marco, you've been
taking an MRI?
Oh man. You mean
when these people?
Maybe it's the same reason
they're anti-mask too.
You know, Marco has probably
been wearing it over his eyes.
Banging is nuts in the stuff
10, 20 times a day.
And here I am,
giving him a hard time.
I'm sorry, bro. I'm sorry.
Look, it sucks for normal people
who have to wait
in long lines for COVID tests,
but Rubio is a senator it would
literally taken 30 seconds.
I can tell you, because I still
get tested three times a week,
even though I've had
three shots and got COVID,
I'm basically super immune now.
The other day,
just to test my immune system,
I got on the F train,
took my mask off and did this.
And I didn't get COVID,
I did catch mange.
Which isn't great, but,
you know,
I still prove my point.
Again, this was a joint address
to Congress and yeah,
I'm a little lightheaded
from how I breathed.
It's touch and go now,
whether or not
I'll make it through the "Look."
And again, this was
a joint address to Congress,
where the president
praised brave Ukrainians
for resisting
Russian aggression
and laid out his plan
to deter Putin,
among many other things.
And Rubio just skipped it
because he didn't want
to get his nose swabbed.
I mean, sorry, man,
but you don't get to say
no thanks
when you have
an important work meeting.
Certainly the rest of us
don't have that option.
I can't just skip
our show's annual
Respect
in the Workplace Meeting
because I don't want
to get a COVID test.
Even our cue card guy,
Wally couldn't skip it.
Although he definitely
put in the bare minimum effort
by zooming
into the meeting,
and this is 100% real
while lying on his bed.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Again, this is a real
a real screenshot
from a Respect
in the Workplace Meeting.
We'll even put an arrow in
so you can see where he is.
And if that shot looks familiar,
that's because he showed up
at the State of the Union
last night.
-I think I have a better idea
to fight inflation.
Lower your cost, not your wages.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-So, Rubio, now you're doing it
with the cards, Wally?
-Yeah. Hey, Seth, you know,
from what I remember,
I'm pretty sure the Respect
in the Workplace Seminar
also said you shouldn't
tease employees on national TV.
-Put the cards up, Wally!
-Alright.
[ Light laughter ]
-So Rubio couldn't be bothered
to show up
to a State of the Union address.
Meanwhile, some of the
Republicans who did show up
were disruptive ass[bleep]
like Lauren Boebert
and Marjorie Taylor Greene.
First, they pulled the dumb
stunt where they turned
their back on Biden's cabinet
as they entered the chamber.
Although, I genuinely can't tell
if they're turning their backs
or if they are just wasted and
don't know which way to look.
I mean, they have the vibe
and posture
of two college sophomores
at a party
looking for a friend
who left hours ago.
[ Imitates female voice ]
Jessica!
[ Laughter ]
Jessica.
[ Normal voice ]
And was that supposed to
be a powerful statement?
You don't look like
you're turning your backs,
so you look like
you're waiting for your Uber
after getting kicked out of an
Applebee's on St. Patrick's Day
for drinking one, too many
Tipsy Leprechauns.
By the way, that is a real thing
you can order an Applebee's.
It's the drink most offensive
to Irish people
since they stopped serving
their IRA themed sparkling wine.
The Troubles Bubbles.
[ Laughter ]
Aaanyway.
Greene and Boebert
weren't done there,
they later heckled Biden
during the part of his speech
on immigration by yelling
"Build the wall" at him.
They were drowned out
by applause,
but there's a photo of them
yelling during the speech
where they look like
too overbearing
Little League moms berating
their kids from the stands.
[ Imitates mom yelling ]
Come on, Tyler, you
got to catch that!
This is T-ball, Tyler!
[ Normal voice ] Now that
picture might make you angry,
but if I've learned anything.
Any one thing from watching
"Real Housewives,"
it's that two white ladies
this erratic will eventually
turn on one another.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, sure, they agree now,
but you wait, you just wait.
[ As Greene] Did you take my
"stop the steal" mask?
[ As Boebert ] I borrowed it.
[ As Greene ]
Well, stop the borrow!
[ Normal voice ] All these
people want is attention,
and they're willing to do
anything to get it,
including yelling
at the President
during an address to the nation.
And look, I don't care
that much about decorum.
I do care about
not being annoying.
And these two are some of
the most annoying people
I've ever seen
on the national stage.
I mean, they're like
a nonstop national hangnail.
They remind me of the kids
in high school
who thought they should be
starring in the school musical,
even though they couldn't
sing for [bleep]
so they'd be in the background,
wearing a tree costume
and would just creep up stage
during the final number.
And then as for the Democrats,
there was Senate Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer,
who preemptively started
applauding a line
Biden's speech before Biden
actually got to it,
producing this awkward moment.
-Unlike the $2 trillion tax
cut passed
in the previous administration
that benefited the top
one percent of Americans
the American Rescue Plan --
[ Booing ]
The American Rescue Plan
help working people
and left no one behind.
-He looked like the overeager
dad at the high school play
who tries to start an ovation
for his two weird nieces.
How about them?
They didn't know all the words,
but they sure have moxie.
No? Okay.
Now, it won't surprise you
to hear
that Biden began his speech
with a strong denunciation
of Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine.
He applauded the bravery
and courage of Ukrainians
defending their country
and announced plans
to go after the wealth
of Russian oligarchs
with an ad-libbed line
at the end,
teasing that there's potentially
more to come.
-Tonight,
I say to the Russian oligarchs
and the corrupt leaders
who bilked billions of dollars
off this violent regime,
"No more."
The United States --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean it.
The United States'
Department of Justice
is assembling
a dedicated task force
to go after the crimes
of the Russian oligarchs.
We're joining
with European allies
to find and seize their yachts,
their luxury apartments,
their private jets.
We're coming for your
ill begotten gains,
and tonight I'm announcing
that we will join our allies
in closing off American airspace
to all Russian flights.
Further isolating Russia
and adding additional squeeze
on their economy.
[ Applause ]
-Whoa, that's quite the tease.
Putin has no idea what's coming.
Looks like someone
prepped for his speech
by watching "Taken" again.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I'll be impressed
if that's true,
because villains like Putin
always like to think
they know what's coming.
I'm betting no one's ever seen
Putin make a shocked expression
in his life.
I don't even know
what that would look like.
Can you imagine throwing
a surprise party for him?
Surprise!
[ As Putin ] No, not surprise.
I read your text
for the last month.
Also, I do not like clapping
for birthdays, Chuck.
Better Chuck, better.
[ Normal voice ]
And true to Biden's word,
today, the Justice Department
followed through and announced
a new task force to go after
Russian elites
called KleptoCapture
to track down wealth
of sanctioned Russian oligarchs
aimed at ensuring the U.S.
can seize the money
of sanctioned
Russian elite tied to Putin.
Now, the name KleptoCapture
is a reference
to capturing the wealth
of Russian kleptocrats.
So we're going after oligarchs,
plutocrats, and kleptocrats.
I'm sorry,
but why do we have so many
different words
for rich criminal?
I feel like I have to walk
around with a damn thesaurus
all day
just to understand the news.
Why can't we just call it
the Taking Money
From Suspiciously Wealthy
Beet Farmers Task Force?
[ Laughter ]
KleptoCapture sounds like
the name of a lesser known
Bond movie from the '80s
starring Roger Moore.
[ British accent ]
Bad news, James. After
you defeated Moonraker,
they came up with an even
more powerful weapon.
It's called KleptoCapture.
[ As Bond ] What does it do?
[ British accent ] Hold on, let
me flip through my thesaurus.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
But there's certainly a lot
of elite Russian wealth
to go after,
in addition to the yachts
and condos and private jets,
the U.S. and its allies
are also going after
a special type of passport
that apparently only rich
oligarchs get to use.
-There will be a trans-Atlantic
international task force
to target wealthy Russians
who have luxury yachts,
luxury apartments,
and use golden passports.
Those are the things
that essentially allow you
to become a citizen
of another country
to either hide your wealth
or escape Russia.
There's such a thing
as a golden passport.
I guess that would explain
why every time I go to JFK,
there's a special line
of security
filled with Russian oligarchs
complaining about
how slow the TSA is.
[ Brooklyn accent ]
Shoes and belts off.
[ Russian accent ]
But I have golden passport.
[ Brooklyn accent ] Buddy,
I don't care if you got
the golden goose.
Shoes and belts off
and no liquids.
[ Russian accent ]
But golden passport
allowed me four ounces.
[ Brooklyn accent ] Willy Wonka
over here got a golden passport.
Willy Wonkavich over here.
What are you taking
the glass elevator?
You got one ticket?
Yeah, I'm reading
a lot of Roald Dahl at home.
[ Normal voice ]
Now, Biden is anticipating
that some of these sanctions
and the instability caused
by the conflict may contribute
to inflation and rising
gas prices, among other things.
So we took a moment to speak
directly to the American people
and tried to reassure them
that everything would be fine.
-To all Americans,
I'll be honest with you,
as I always promised I would be,
a Russian dictator aff--
invading a foreign country
has cost around the world.
And I'm taking robust action
to make sure
the pain of our sanctions
is targeted at Russian economy.
And that we use every tool
at our disposal
to protect American businesses
and consumers.
These steps will help blunt
gas prices here at home,
but I know news about
what's happening
can seem
alarming to all Americans.
But I want you to know
we're going to be okay.
We're going to be okay.
-You know, things aren't
exactly going great
when the President adopts
the tone of a husband who just
told his wife he blew all their
money at the racetrack.
"We're going to be okay, baby.
I've got a plan.
My buddy, Chuck and I
are going to start a business
selling fake Nike's
in Times Square."
Chuck, tell her
how good the plan is."
Chuck!
Oh, Chuck, come on.
Don't do me like this man."
Last night, Biden applauded
the bravery and courage
of the Ukrainian people
and laid out
a strong response to Russia
that will punish them
financially while being careful
to avoid
any direct military conflict
that could drastically
escalate the situation
which no one wants.
And yet some Republicans
couldn't even be bothered
to show up,
while others were just
disruptive jerks.
Every time I remember
these insane people
are elected officials,
I have to look in the mirror
and tell myself
we're going to be okay.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year to
men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.